les laurent a dit qu'il était encore
tout seul il serait resté qu'il suffit
que je te disais d1 répondu moi j'aurais
aimé continuer avec lui ouais
je je je le dis et je le répète c'est
vrai qu'il continue avec lui et qu'ils
ont compris que moi je crois que federer
était j'ai compris on le rend compte et
quand tu es seul depuis pendant des
années et qu'on me demande de coanimer
avec quelqu'un franchement c'est
compliqué il y déjà je trouve qu'il est
il a eu l'élégance de dire oui au débat
et de dire je vais le tenter après c'est
vrai que c'est pas senti dans la
coanimation long et je peux le
comprendre tout à fait mais voilà mais
c'est la vérité c'est qu'il ya quatre
ans il m'a invité à déjeuner à la fin on
n'est pas couché il m'a proposé de
revenir co présentée avec lui on n'est
pas couché ouais je vous assure que c
est ce que c'est vrai que tu avais
commencé moi j'avais commencé avec lui
on a lutté sa chroniqueuse je suis
heureuse de sa chroniqueuse j'étais
heureuse de sa co-présentatrice moi je
les regardais faire pendant un an j'ai
appris en le regardant c'est un très bon
j'aurais pu continuer avec lui plusieurs
années je peux comprendre qu'au bout de
dix sept ans il est pas envie salle
souge d'ascendant 17 ans il a fait cette
chose là je crois que ce sont eux voilà
un vrai jeu il a décidé ça et c'est plus
tu vois les gens qui le respecte mais
j'aurais continué matthew lillard sais
pas c'est pas vraiment pardon c'est pas
pour le défendre c'est pas vraiment les
gars qui va arrêter là cette case il est
dit je ne suis pas heureux à deux donc
sous-entendu si je suis seule je reste
est ce que vous vous êtes dit peut-être
une seconde ok c'est pas moins de
récupérer la case puisqu'on n'était pas
heureux à 2 je m'en vais et je te laisse
te baise moi moi moi honnêtement je les
dis très clairement à la chaîne moi j'ai
dit oui la chaîne qui a décidé mais vous
savez moi j'ai essayé le convaincre de
rester mois gérer dit ce serait cool de
risque c'est bien le même sabot mission
bah non c'est ça non je dis c'est moi je
dis ça y est elle est seulement il
valait peut-être même moi je vais faire
autre chose et garde ta gorge mais bon
ça se passe pas comme ça ça peut se
passer comme ça quand même
oui honnêtement c'est une belle phrase
j'ai essayé de le convaincre de rester
parce qu'on lançait ce truc là
l'émission commence mais vous l'avez
fait cyril vous l'avez fait gérald
émission avec laurent je me suis régalé
dit à l'époque qu'il était un idiot qui
marche a dit qu'il était voilà mais
c'est vrai que là je pense que
sincèrement c'est vrai que quand
quelqu'un arrive moi je n'aurais pas qu
on m voilà quelqu'un à côté tout tout de
suite attendait d'eux trois mois mais
c'est vrai que voilà et série call avec
christophe j'ai l'impression que le
doubs
naturellement c'est pas pareil c'est
cesser ses émissions d'un de ses
missions elle est alors alors sachez que
moi je suis juste bâton de berger
poser comme invité principal voyez on va
me poser comme ça que tu réagis à tout
aussi de bottes à tous
oui je travaillais beaucoup mieux bah
oui c'est vrai on se connaît bien ta
tête tu as dit oui tout de suite à cette
position qu aucun problème mais c'est
une nouvelle aventure moi c'est tout ce
qui m'amuse c'est une nouvelle aventure
cgt 30 ans le parrainage des émissions
ça m'amuse beaucoup de voir si
d'ailleurs c'est sur que oui vu comment
entend donc de tenir une position
seconde je m'en fous la manière dont
moi-même partage dechavanne c'est très
étonnant moi je commence à avancer avec
lui et il est vachement la transmission
en fait ils m'appellent in dit tu
devrais faire ça tu devrais faire six
fois ou où les généraux
ils achetaient fige ça pas besoin de tes
filles ça plus me dit sourit péter
bottini les producteurs il a sonné et ça
m'aide énormément et ça me pose aucun
souci mais vraiment à m'en remettre
tecteo re l'abbé samain ou franchement
sont là devant moi j'avais rangé mes
cartons j'étais prêt à se remettre les
mains dans la terre avec musharraf mais
quand tu les appeler pour leur dire on
n'aime pas keith aux
besoins de base comme tous les cas
plutôt qu'un copain non non je sais que
j'ai pas non non non je vois pas
pourquoi on définit pas ce contrat avec
lorient non enfin je suis je m'entends
très bien avec eux j'ai des projets avec
le tissu impératrice mais alors ça ça va
des projets avec tf1 ou non du projet
sur frein j'ai des projets avec la
maison ici je sais ici l écart jeunes
avec les jeunes je suis producteur jay
charge d'âmes j'ai des guides
collaborateurs et je fais ça vraiment
mais avec un engouement de gains parce
que c'est nouveau